thoughts on the zyto scans that many acupuncturists said nutritionists are running these days are
they accurate and identified bacteria and viruses. I'd say yes and no so that I think they're
beneficial on the frequency scans can be beneficial to identify that a person may have a bacteria
or a virus, but I've always said they are not something that you would quote unquote
diagnose off of. So if it's another test, for instance, if I run a CBC and I have an elevated
white blood cell code and I didn't have an elevated white blood cell code in my previous CBCs,
then I could say that there's a high likelihood that I have an infection. That I would compare that
with the differential of the complete blood count. If my neutrophils were elevated and my lymphocytes
were suppressed, I'd say that it's a pretty good chance that it's a bacterial infection.
If that was reversed, my lymphocytes were elevated, my neutrophils were suppressed,
and it's a pretty good chance that it's a viral infection. But can I just run a zyto scan to know
if it's a bacteria or a virus? It will give you clues. I think a blood test is going to give you
more accurate clues. Remember, a zyto scan is picking up frequencies, and it's picking up frequencies
quite quickly. So there could be a lot of errors in that as well. My argument against the scans is
when practitioners use it and tell people you have Lyme disease or you have this disease.
I think that's dangerous. I don't think it's accurate. I don't think it's proper medicine. I think
that's, is it mild practice? Any more than some of the things that the medical doctor says,
I don't think you can just diagnose based upon just one test of anything. All your tests give you
clues. Yes. If you came up high in, let's say you came up positive online on a zyto scan.
Does that mean you have Lyme? In my book? No. It doesn't mean you have Lyme. Does it mean that you
could have bacteria and or viruses? Yes. If you came up very high in multiple bacterias and they gave
you the name of the bacteria when I diagnosed it and said, this is the exact bacteria that you have
based upon this zyto scan. I would say no, but is there a greater chance that you may have a
bacterial infection? Yes, but you'd compare it with other labs too. If your CBC was normal,
your white blood cell, let's say, was 4.5. And your neutrophils in the facites were within normal
range too, but then you showed high bacteria on a zyto scan. I would doubt that that was accurate.
Is there anything wrong with doing some treatment on the right based upon the zyto scan? Absolutely not.
It's not going to be invasive. Nothing like that. Would you use an antibiotic based upon a positive
bacteria on a zyto scan? No, I wouldn't because that's going to be more invasive. So,
long story short, any test that you do, it has imperfections. Nothing is going to be perfect gold
standard. So, you use a test wisely to give you clues. So, your run as a zyto scan, you came up
positive for virus. Let's say, Epstein-Barr virus. Does that mean that you have Epstein-Barr virus?
I would say no, it doesn't. You would look at other tests as well. If your white blood cell count
again was within normal range and your lymphocyte count was within normal range, this zyto scan could have
been picking up a past Epstein-Barr virus. Most of us have latent Epstein-Barr virus. If you did an
IgG antibody test for Epstein-Barr virus, probably eight out of ten people would show positive and yet
not have any signs of current Epstein-Barr virus because almost everybody has been exposed to
Epstein-Barr virus. So, like I said, then the zyto scan picks it up and then people run with that say,
you have Epstein-Barr virus. That's your problem and we need to treat for this. So, they go in a whole
treatment program for that and it's not accurate. So, I would just be careful using any test as your
gold standard. Use every test as giving you clues and guiding your treatment and so there's
nothing wrong with using it if you just use it wisely with that understanding.